so hi everybody my name is Matt maroon
I'm the CEO and co-founder of watt learn
why learn is a startup company based
here in Pittsburgh where we're building
an artificial intelligence software
platform to better manage battery
systems
so basically we're using machine
learning to give batteries of brain help
them maximize both the value and life of
those systems on the grid but today
we're gonna talk about next generation
in energy storage systems so I think
everyone recognizes over the past 10
years or so batteries have been been a
ubiquitous part of our life
so from batteries that we now carry
everywhere with us to electric vehicles
to the batteries that are being
installed on the grid to manage
intermittency of renewables provide
backup power and all sorts of other grid
services so what we're going to talk
about here with the panel that's would
say much smarter than me are what's
happening in research so everything from
advanced materials to how we measure and
collect and analyze data how is all of
that giving better information to make
better systems to make better battery
technologies so just moving down to
introductions so I don't don't think I
need to introduce Jay who's the
moderator of today's session next to Jay
is Ted Wiley so Ted is the co-founder
and CEO of forum energy
Ted began his career with the US Army is
an infantry officer and then went on to
become co-founder and head of product at
aqua energy before moving to form he was
president of McDonough innovation and
form is a startup focused on long
duration energy storage to really enable
widespread adoption of renewables so
moving closer and closer to base load
next to Ted Venkat Viswanathan he is the
assistant professor of mechanical
chemical engineering and material
science here at Carnegie Mellon his
research group has led has brought
expertise in energy storage and
lithium-ion specifically as they pertain
to electric vehicles and planes
his focus is on identifying the
scientific principles governing material
design in organic organic and
biomaterials for novel anarchy energy
conversion and storage routes next James
Fleetwood who's the research director
for the battery Innovation Centre in
south-central Indiana he works with the
cell manufacturing team at the battery
Innovation Center which fabricates novel
electrode materials optimizes
performance parameters with a focus on
prototype performance evaluation and
scale-up to commercialization
and lastly Eli Leland the co-founder and
chief product officer of voltaic Eli
serves as a company's chief product
officer in guides the voltaic product
roadmap as well as post-sale customer
experience Eli and his co-founder tall
started voltaic in 2012 in order to
address data analysis workflow
challenges that they personally
encountered while running RPE energy
storage Research Projects at SUNY Energy
Institute in New York City thank you so
much Matt and I could quickly thank our
distinguished panel for coming and I've
asked Matt to sit up here as well mainly
because he's so handsome some of that
help Ted also told me to start with the
joke so so I'm gonna ask each panelist
first the same question and they're
gonna answer from their own context what
they think about it and we have a couple
of those and some individual questions
then we'll open it up to the floor so
please do use the app and the
instructions around the table to use
that so I guess I'll start with Ted and
the first question is about sort of what
happened what's happened in the past 10
years and I was thinking last night it
was 9 about 9 years ago you and I were
on the fourth floor of Wayne Hall in my
cinderblock office writing a five
million dollar proposal to the do e to
get ARRA money which we won and we just
made some real tall promises and we
delivered on those
and then sort of a chaos ensued but and
and so you start off but I'd love to
hear everyone else's opinion what has
happened in your world in the past ten
years of energy storage just to frame
the context as we talk about next
generation research yeah that's great
ten years ago I was in business school
and a really amazing kind of important
thing happened to me there was this
field study class called building green
businesses and each the groups of two or
three students got to select a project
and work with somebody out in the
outside world on something in the green
clean tech space and me and two others
selected a project called stealth
battery company which was backed by
kleiner perkins and that was Jay and
what happened was kleiner had provided
some research money to Jay to start
evaluating new alternatives to ultra
low-cost energy storage so over the
subsequent six months we did a field
study project for Jay at the end of
which I was looking for a job because I
was graduating from my MBA and the
kleiner partner suggested I come out and
meet Jay and see if it might be
interesting to help him spin the company
out of his lab at Carnegie Mellon I came
out here in May of 2009 and who we
immediately got along we had a shared
worldview a shared passion for
sustainability and clean energy and we
said yeah let's do this so I moved to
Pittsburgh full-time and I lived there
for the next six years I met my wife at
that time lithium-ion batteries were
about twelve hundred dollars a kilowatt
hour you know Dave mentioned a
precipitous decline from you know a
thousand dollars a kilowatt hour in 2010
to you know maybe in the in the hundreds
to a hundred now for the battery pack we
Jay and I started aqueon energy which
was an alternative to lithium-ion for
stationary energy storage
we built a manufacturing our team built
a manufacturing facility Matt was on our
team as are some others that are in the
audience today and we we sort of went
through what I might call battery 1.0
which
was developing technologies and trying
to find an application in the market to
use them for and thinking about also how
do you make the market for energy
storage so how do you develop the
technology how do you find a useful
application and how do you convince
people to buy it so we were we were
creating a market as an industry at the
same time we were creating technologies
and you know at that time the biggest
batteries that were being deployed were
you know megawatt batteries 1 megawatt
for 15 minutes for instance and you know
today hundreds too soon thousands of
megawatt hours of batteries are being
deployed yearly around the world so the
you know this has gone from an
experimental idea that was really at the
fringe of the global electricity
industry to something that people
consider to be one of the big solutions
going forward for the grid and it's been
incredible to watch and be a part of
yeah so ten years ago roughly I started
graduate school and I came to Stanford
and I think one useful thing that
happened was I I did my undergrad at IIT
which is a place of perfect competition
and so one amazing thing that happened
was most of my friends close friends
ended up on the East Coast and so I was
sort of the loner there on the west
coast and that fundamentally changed my
thinking at least in terms of decoupling
difficulty of problem and importance of
problem and I think that sort of is my
journey into becoming an accidental
electric chemist so I started my
graduate school and wanted to work on
fluid mechanics which is if you're if
you did mechanical engineering as an
undergrad that's probably one of the
topics that you would think is hard I I
came in to graduate school in the
division of computational fluid dynamics
quickly realized there are not many
important things to be done in that
field and then the second accident that
happened was I did a summer internship
at Bosch and they defined a problem in
batteries and I done nothing in
things up until that point this is just
a message to many of you that may be
thinking about getting into batteries
and I have no background I had no
background eight years ago and I'm here
so so I think that you know everyone can
get there by spending the right amount
of time on it
so I I switched sort of midway through
my PhD to think on lithium ion and and
next generation chemistry is related to
lithium air and and i i i interviewed
here actually as a graduate student j
was Jay was in the audience and and he
asked the sort of meanest toughest
questions when I was interviewing the
seminars up on YouTube so there's like
proof that that happened and so then I
started my then I came here after a
brief stint at MIT and I I came here
started a group largely thinking about
electrification mostly on vehicles and
the sort of big question that we were
trying to answer was was how can we
design organic electrolytes I think that
was the one piece that I felt there was
a lot of art to it and we wanted to try
and change that process of thinking
about electrolytes and so I'm not an
organic chemist so we thought about Big
Data long before Big Data was was sort
of a huge buzz word but I think you know
we've we've made phenomenal progress you
know I lead a team of or 20 other
accidental electro chemists and I think
they will all like test that but I think
that's it has been phenomenal to have a
group of very interesting mix from you
know physics chemical engineering Mackey
material science and so on so I think
it's been a great journey and and you
know I look forward to the the next ten
years of my career looking at you know
battery 2.0 I guess
James alright ten years ago I was also
thinking about grad school just about to
enter I was actually excited for working
at a gas turbine engine manufacturer
I've always been interested in energy
storage energy conversion energy
generation and so I started off gas
turbine engines demo barrier coatings
and I saw this opportunity for fuel
cells and I ended up doing all my grad
school work on hydrogen fuel cells
particularly developing the solid
electrolytes and along the way the BIC
was just they were just building the
Foundation's at the time and near the
end they had opened the doors and I
started to hear this opportunity I'd
also spent all this time in grad school
on some very interesting work you know a
lot of people I ended up working at the
BIC worked on various fuel cells a
polymer is more more commonly me solid
oxide fuel cell certainly a very
efficient form and working on solid
electrolyte gave me some interesting
experience there but I wanted to be a
little bit closer to something in in a
more practical use widespread use I saw
that and that lithium-ion batteries had
developed so much and I saw that the BIC
was in that facilitator role that final
hurdle to take it from university to
end-user
to help these help early researchers
with very minimal amounts of money
access the equipment that they need to
prove their technology on a larger scale
large enough that the big million cell
per year plus manufacturers are going to
go out there and and really look at them
seriously and trust the data from that
third party so it's a very exciting
opportunity and I did find that as I
mentioned a fair number of people that
I've worked with in the battery industry
now were fuel cell workers in the past I
think that's that's been a jump that
I've noticed is a lot of fuel cell
researchers kind of are jumping on board
the battery train both technologies of
course have very good application to the
future but here we're talking about
batteries and energy storage and
that's where I've started really was
three and a half years ago and in terms
of lithium-ion batteries and I would say
half of the work that we've done at the
BIC in that time has all been developing
various aspects of the silicon chemistry
from active material makers to binder
makers to electrolyte makers every every
little piece has really been necessary
and that can be the challenges everyone
has one of the pieces of the solution
and the big tries to make them share
that information but everyone of course
it's very difficult to develop a product
and protect your intellectual property
but I would say that most of the
individual pieces of the technology are
out there and that it's a matter of
sharing your information and you would
actually get there that would be high
silicon content commercial cells so I
mean you guys are a test house right so
you get these samples in or units in
from a variety of places and test them
yes we I've probably worked with maybe a
dozen different silicon anode developers
they send whatever piece of the prop of
the n cell that they make they send it
to us we work in some sort of
collaborative way they maybe come to the
pick as well and we try to develop their
cell as a collaborative process and test
it with a independent party wolof
between the different competitors I
presume - yes it's a careful process but
we've managed we managed and then
there's one of the other things we try
to do is if there is something that's
shared with the opportunity to share we
basically have like a black box process
you can put your thing every company can
put their thing into the black box we
don't tell you what it is but we'll show
you the performance results after the
fact and if they're so stunning maybe
you'll start sharing that information
and that has actually happened in the
past but yeah for the most part silicon
has been where we've seen a lot of
development and electrolyte and high
voltage electrolytes okay it's been the
big part of the work I'd say
Italy I like the rest of my co-panelists
I was in school 10 years ago finishing a
PhD in mechanical engineering I had
nothing to do with batteries I knew I
wanted to work on energy wasn't quite
sure where to go with it
brief detour through DC in a policy
fellowship decided I did not want to go
that route either really wanted to go
back to working on technology so I had
an opportunity to move to New York City
to lead an RPE research project
developing a new type of capacitor based
power converter DC to DC converter for
electricity and in that same lab there
was another RPE project working on a new
grid scale energy storage technology
based on alkaline materials so basically
taking the the cheap materials in a
Duracell battery and scaling it up
making them cyclic for grid applications
so in that lab I was I was in my work I
was leading a team that was developing
capacitors were making lots of
prototypes were doing a lot of testing a
lot of data analysis and my counterpart
on the grid scale storage process
project was doing the same and you know
we had our group of developed some very
rudimentary tools to help us accelerate
those data analysis workflows basically
so we could look at the our data in a
web browser instead of having to go into
the lab and download it on a USB stick
put in a spreadsheet etcetera and with
apologies to our sponsors at arpa-e
it turned out that the those software
tools that we were working with are
actually generating a lot more
commercial interest than the energy
storage technologies that we were
developing on those grants they were
helping us get papers out faster get
patents out faster and we were actually
you know people who would come through
to visit the lab actually wanted to know
about how could could they get the
software that we were using rather than
you know could they license or partner
with the center hardware you know so we
took that hint that there might be a
commercial opportunity to build a
software platform a software product
targeted specifically towards the
engineering analysis
in batteries and energy storage and
their applications so that's what we did
and we you know early on we one of those
one of those enquiries about you know
could they get their hands on our
software we took that opportunity to do
a sort of one-off consulting project as
a proof-of-concept myself and my
co-founder the guy was leading the the
battery project who actually had
previously done fuel cells as well
before he moved over to batteries so we
did that proof-of-concept project we
raised SBIR grant money from Department
of Energy National Science Foundation to
get the company off the ground and sort
of scaled it from there and you know
here that was 2012 and here we are about
six years later and you know we're
working with companies sort of across
the spectrum of batteries in their
applications from early-stage R&D other
independent test centers automotive
companies consumer electronics sort of
you know we sort of found this
opportunity in this gigantic global
industry of batteries and energy storage
and their applications which in
aggregate is a huge global market and
there's really a need for dedicated
software tools in that market so that's
that's that's what we're building as a
company voltaic I'd say the other thing
you know that early on led to this
inspiration was not being a battery
person originally and sitting in a lab
at City College of New York with a bunch
of other battery researchers I was
hearing people complain constantly about
how the state of the art of predictive
models for battery performance was
terrible in academia industry people are
doing trying all kinds of like
supercomputer simulations things like
that and and not really coming up with a
lot of practical results and so you know
perhaps being naive I I sort of asked
the question well is anybody taking the
big data approach and just trying to
collect as much data as you can and and
be empirical so look at the you know the
actual performance data of how these
batteries are performing as well as you
know all the metadata that you can get
about how they were built
what sort of process these materials etc
and it turned out that that nobody was
doing that and one of the big reasons
was that nobody could
yet enough data into one place in order
to you know get a meaningful data set
that we're useful in that kind of study
so that's sort of the dual there's sort
of two things that we're focused on it
voltaic is really getting all that data
into one place and then doing
interesting and valuable things with it
for our customers perfect things so this
is evidence that if you want to work in
batteries don't start studying batteries
you should move on to something else
later on no I mean and this is one of
the main reasons I wanted to eat your
personal stories out a little bit is in
fact what's happened in the past decade
is that there was almost no battery
research in North America ten years ago
very little and there's been such an
influx of funding or interest in indeed
you know markets that have evolved in
the past decade that you've seen these
holes filled by people like this who
have seen the opportunity responded to
funding from the Delian and RB in other
places and have created entire careers
and industry around it so it's super
exciting that this whole class of people
for each one on the on the stage before
you there's tens and tens and hundreds
elsewhere in the United States who are
like them so this is a huge movement
that's occurred in part because of folks
like da Danielson and others who have
pulled the trigger on a lot of funding
and support for energy storage so the
need is there the perceived need the
real need and this is the answer to
those questions
alright so second question and we try to
go a little bit faster here now that we
sort of set the stage what is battery
2.0 when I say battery 2.0 to you what
does it mean okay I have some ideas
about this and I'll try to go quickly to
your point battery 1.0 to me was
technology driven I think that the major
innovations that will happen will be led
by the market need this time and that
means that there's going to be
sophisticated tech know economic
modeling that starts from the beginning
and considers the full landed system I'm
thinking mostly stationary batteries
here but probably also in cars it will
be market needs driven for the
innovations and that that market need
will drive the technology development
process I think that for there's
probably two classes of battery 2.0
high-performing
and very very low cost and in particular
for very low cost I think that battery
2.0 will not really have synthetic
chemicals involved it's going to be
simple naturally occurring very abundant
materials because we need to go down an
order of magnitude more in cost
they can't 2.0 I tried I'll try to get
to this as fast as possible so to get to
2.0 we need to know where one point out
has darkness and and so I think largely
this is sort of my current thesis one
point with one point oh we will
electrify nearly all markets of
transportation including heavy-duty
trucking with some slight changes in
behavior and probably with some
enhancements and charging which will
happen so which means then the question
is we know what is 2.0 and and for me
personally you know I think the the
biggest the biggest omission at least
from a personal stance standpoint is
flying
I fly a hundred thousand miles a year
not proud of it
and my body doesn't like it and so we
would like to try and Electrify planes I
think it's not as hard as it might
imagine so I think that's one piece of
battery 2.0 at least personally the
second thing which I think gets to many
of the things that people have been
talking about is in the battery business
the problem is when people tell you
something
there's people tell you many things all
of which could be true but they're all
never simultaneously true and and so as
a result this sort of a huge mistrust in
the battery field and I think part of
this is is that it's a hard problem
you know multiphysics multi-dimensional
and so on so I think data is going to be
a key layer as we go forward and so I
think having data fill the gap
and and be the sort of driver of
innovation towards all these next
generation chemistry's either for sort
of high performance for aviation or
other markets and for things like long
duration storage I think data and sort
of high performance markets are sort of
two things that I think 2.0 batteries
will be about James so I'm getting the
impression we're talking a step change
now kind of beating off of what the
previous panelists have said battery 2.0
is a step change from where we're at now
some some new application real change
not just the incremental improvements
that we've been talking about as far as
no higher nickel content or lessening
the weight lowering the cost as you said
yet fundamentally lowering the cost
would be a battery 2.0 and I still think
that battery 1.0 still has a lot of
legroom in the in the sense that we're
talking here at the cathode theoretical
capacities there's still a lot left in
the tank there and even integration of
things like the conversion based anodes
not necessarily a step change just
another larger increment of improvement
and so to me battery 2.0 would actually
possibly involve a fundamental change in
the manufacturing processes themselves
right now we're pretty much just in the
process we have now because of magnetic
tape decks in the 80s and CDs in the 90s
a whole lot of equipment came offline
someone found its big it out a way to
use that equipment for something that
could make some money with it and we
just keep on making all these
incremental changes with it and when I
think of the truly next-generation
energy storage technologies some of them
are not entirely compatible with this
tape casting method that we use now
where we have solid particles and the
interfaces of solid particles are
difficult to control
I'm sure there's everyone's barely aware
of the solid electrolyte interface
issues and columbic efficiency issues
that ultimately lead to poor shelf life
and course cycle life and many other
problems
these are all surface scientists are all
interface issues and they all come back
to the manufacturing process now there's
certainly plenty of incremental changes
we can do to improve it different
electrolytes high voltage electrolytes
additives all these things are battery
1.0 though battery 2.0 is more likely to
be in my mind something like a
solid-state battery which would probably
involve a different manufacturing
process since the inherent porosity
created and traditional manufacturing is
not entirely compatible with ideal
solid-state chemistry so it should
surprise knowing that my vision for
battery 2.0 involves data it's very
heavily data centric and I appreciate
Ben Katz remarks run along those lines
but to flesh that out a little further
what we see is you know if you look at
batteries today every battery that's
doing anything you know even remotely
valuable or important is is generating
data whether it's in a test lab whether
it's during the manufacturing process
during the formation cycling that
happens toward the end of that process
whether it's being integrated into a
product you or used in an application or
then repurposed at the end of life there
is data being collected on those
batteries all across that chain and so
our vision for battery 2.0 is really to
connect those dots throughout the the
full lifecycle of a battery so that you
have sort of traceability of that
battery's origin and how its performed
and sort of what its health and what its
quality is throughout that lifecycle and
you know we we sort of see that in our
work with our customers sort of being
pulled in that direction sort of both up
and down the supply chain in terms of
there being a desire for more data
exchange and transparency between the
material suppliers and manufacturers
manufacturers and the you know consumer
electronics or electric vehicle
applications and then even once they
ship those products out the door with
the financial community that's going to
be ensuring those fleets of vehicles or
those batteries on the grid at scale so
we sort of see data as the layer that
connects all those dots and
can facilitate that future vision
perfect so I've got one more general
question for you guys then we'll break
it down to individual questions or
questions from the audience so please if
you're thinking of things uh enter them
now speak now or forever hold your peace
a couple years ago I was drafted to a
National Academies panel and I did an
assessment of our petit part of the
exercise was to assess their energy
storage portfolio and at the time they
had circuit 2015 they had funded 63
separate storage related projects to the
tune of somewhere between 200 and 250
million dollars depending on how you
count cost-sharing at the same time do
you we had founded you know a variety of
centers the biggest one in which of G is
JC's er that's hosted at Argonne
National Lab and so that was a big sort
of focal point of the UE along with all
these different projects everywhere
innervation centric at arpa-e and NSF
had a handful of things as well so there
is a general huge uptick in funding from
the US government that spurned a lot of
this as I mentioned the question that I
have to you guys is and we've all
benefited from it one way or another is
this still going in the right direction
this should our indie policy or R&D
around energy storage or batteries be
altered given all we've talked about
battery 1.0 a battery 2.0 knowing that
in Asia there are you know and there are
rooms with hundreds of PhDs who are
doing incremental improvement on the
current technologies and they are doing
it in a brutal way that is hard to
compete with what happens here to do the
next thing that's gonna matter that's
gonna move the bar and is this an R&D
function for the government or is this
something that should be more or venture
based I think in the spectrum of rnd
what I would like to see more of is
focus on the D the development portion
of it and in particular I think about a
learning curve like a right curve where
the the total volume of production is
correlated to an exponential price
decline and in order to achieve the
value of that learning curve we need to
produce the volume and so lithium-ion
has
that advantage it is producing at
volumes that are increasing year over
year if we're going to see new
technologies compete we have to give
them a shot that more than the are level
and and that has to be a national
priority if we are going to be the ones
that are gonna capture that flag in the
United States it certainly is a national
priority in China for instance they're
making an eight hundred megawatt hour
flow battery and you know will it cost
down I don't know but the only way to
find out is to you know is to fund the
development effort as well as the
research effort just to follow up on
that I think that there needs to be sort
of more crosstalk between R&D I think
there's a lot of people that work a lot
on either R or either D and I think
there's very little crosstalk in my own
experience and I think some of my
students will attest to this when you
have that link to folks that are that
are constantly thinking about
development that fundamentally changes
your landscape in terms of how you think
about research how you think about
framing your question and and you sort
of know whether what you do will ever
make a difference and I think that's a
really important thing that I think some
of the agencies like goe and arpa-e
encourage of course the challenge with
many of that kind of funding comes sort
of challenging milestones and
deliverables that you know this is
sometimes hard to predict with such
ambitious projects and and obviously
when you want to try and bring anything
new you have to also assume that the
current technology is going to get so
much better and so you have to assume
that you can beat them five years from
now so I think there are some pieces
that are very good with how are PE and
and do e elements that they have in
their funding model but they're I think
taking a longer-term view is of course
challenging but I think would be
something that would greatly benefit
these sorts of very ambitious projects
all right I think I'm definitely
agreeing on a particularly the rnd
separation there that's definitely
something at the BIC that we've seen a
lot where you know in coin cell testing
for instance seems like they solve every
problem you could imagine and they're so
satisfied with that result and then they
try to scale it up and and oftentimes
that coin sale result was fairly
meaningless so by coin sell just to be
clear for the audience these are very
very tiny test cells there are tens of
milligrams of active materials but it
proves function and it's very easy the
wrong word but it's more common to get
stellar results from something small but
of course you have several orders of
magnitude more area the same material
even in a regular battery and then much
more difficult right exactly exactly and
the the the free volume available in
that cell is so much more as far as the
coin cells concerned the electrolyte to
active mass ratio there's just so many
things that on a more geometric basis
for that format just don't translate
very well and additionally as far as the
funding side goes I do because as the
BIC we I don't often look to get our own
grants we usually partner with different
entities that have you know some piece
of technology and we'll partner with
them on a grant to to facilitate it and
so we've seen a whole lot of different
applications and the ones that succeed
and don't and I would generally I
generally think that the better ones do
tend to succeed although the ones that
promise the most to get the grants the
most as well which is which is some some
of what of a challenge I think but
that's hard to hard to fight against
obviously the person promising the most
is the most enticing or the biggest liar
yeah
well the most optimistic you can just be
I like to be I like to be positive and
just say they were the most optimistic
researchers but yes I do think that that
step between early research and later
development and scale-up it could be
bridged a lot more and that's really
what the book is all about was was
creating that bridge and I think we've
had some success in that great so I'm
going to echo a couple of things that
that were said just now which is that I
think a major priority going forward for
battery R&D is to develop metrics so
that you can actually compare different
technologies on a level playing field
and so broadly speaking you know when
you're developing a new battery
technology things are concerned with our
how much energy can it hold how much
power can it deliver how long can you
cycle it how many times can you charge
and discharge it how much does it cost
and how safe is it and so you know I
think that it would be great if there
were some priority around developing a
standard set of metrics to evaluate
every technology along those different
axes it would be fairly straightforward
to propose you know for different
applications where there's
transportation for its storage etc which
ones are more important how they should
be weighted but you know it's sort of I
think that there's an issue in that you
hear so often in the media the sort of
the stories that bubble up to the media
about the newest battery breakthrough
it's somebody has a technology that can
you know we'll be able to charge your
car in 10 seconds your electric vehicle
in 10 seconds or what have you but
almost invariably there's some one of
those acts one or more of those axes of
performance is sort of being hidden and
not talked about and those are important
very relevant and so I think some you
know making it a priority in terms of
research funding where those resources
go being able to evaluate these things
so you can separate out sort of the the
science projects or the you know the
hero cells where you have one battery
that runs for ten thousand cycles you
have no idea why
but from the ones who can generate
statistically significant results that
can be compared and and used to make
those those priority decisions perfect
and I haven't forgot actually Madan want
to I want to pull you in here for a
second I want you to dial back yourself
a good eight or nine years what you
might not know of him as it he was at
General Electric for a little while how
many years two years due to very long
years yes yeah and you're on the DGE
dureth on battery team so you this is
sort of it's an interesting historical
I'm gonna bring this into to a corporate
R&D for batteries just at just so you
know but ge bought purchased a company
called beta battery right and then they
decided they were gonna scale this is a
high-temperature what was it a nickel
sodium sodium yes it a nickel chloride
battery and they poured how much money
into it hundreds of millions yeah at
least hundreds of millions into
manufacturing the team the clean rooms
everything and what happened that's
right and and so I get my question
really is corporate wise the GES of the
world I mean are they diving back in the
new batteries or not like what's where
do people stand so I don't think so I
don't think we're gonna see any
personally I don't think you're gonna
see any big you know fortune 100 company
that's gonna go and start research from
the ground up I think what all those big
companies are doing is hoping that
either something gets through like Ted
said right the D part of it where they
can go out and deploy or they're very
content right now just to buy
off-the-shelf lithium-ion cells from
whoever's the lowest cost supplier
packaged them together and sell it for
whatever margin they can yeah I don't
think they'll you'll see any research
coming out of the big companies yeah and
then the other indicator is Sony
actually the first company to market
lithium-ion batteries Sony is sort of
divesting their battery assets there's
getting out of the business it's a sort
of seen as a race to the bottom low
margin high risk kind of situation so as
we think about R&D and moving forward
there's this open question well who's
gonna take over the tech and
you know if we have something that's so
different a new chemistry solid state
that requires a different manufacturing
infrastructure
who's gonna own that who's gonna put up
the multiple billions to overcome so
there's this tension between incremental
improvement of our current that you know
approach and then the opposite which is
this sort of if you're gonna make a
difference in a radical way who's gonna
flip the bill
we've got breakthrough energy ventures
and other folks like that we're willing
to cede and support four years but can
they convert can they make the thing
this is gonna be an interesting question
about battery 2.0 I think the story is
largely about converting to that like
large-scale production of things we have
about five minutes left one of the
audience questions discuss raw materials
supply issues as bad as as we scale
batteries globally what do you guys
think that the raw materials pain points
are Dave mentioned in his talk cobalt
and lithium is this true and is there
something else we should be looking at
as well anybody thank you so III think
some of this is overstated obviously
cobalt is the most challenging I think
at least one way I think about it is is
you you you have to sort of think about
whether the control of production of
that particular material is is
controlled by one country or many
countries and so for nearly all other
materials including lithium and and
we're not gonna run sure the lithium the
simple arithmetic that you can do all
you need is one mole of lithium and one
mole of transition metal lithium is so
light so you you can do a
back-of-the-envelope looking back at
your periodic table and know that you
know you need one tenth of lithium for
transition metals so lithium is likely
not going to be the bottleneck cobalt
may be there there are many options
related to sort of low cobalt so of
course I think this is a challenge but I
don't think this is something that it's
going to be a huge showstopper yeah and
I could I could add to that I would
agree and I think though that where it
blends together with where it can be
challenging is the price fluctuation
it's the industry is large enough now
that you
the mining consortiums are actually
going to these you know battery shows
and they're paying attention to the
industry since there's so much being
bought now that it actually affects the
decisions on whether to open up and mine
more I definitely think it particularly
nickel and and the others other than
cobalt that as demand increases supply
will follow you'll have those delays
that you can have just like you know
even with oil sometimes supply and
demand don't quite match up and the
price skyrockets I think that's one case
where batteries have a little bit more
flexibility an example would be cell
dissected recently it was technically
they were lying about the cell but still
it worked did the cell worked they just
lied about what was in it
lco recently got very much more
expensive and so they blended in NMC
and it had the same performance
characteristics it worked they should
have been honest about it but still it
leads to what you can do when we have
these flexible chemistry's if one
particular element suddenly gets
expensive we can shift among a few
choice and just for the audience
newcomers to batteries LCLs lithium
cobalt oxide NMC is lithium nickel
cobalt manganese oxide and they have
different ratios and the idea is to play
the game of reducing the amount of
expensive things like cobalt and nickel
while increasing the amount of manganese
without having a crappy battery and this
it's funny how nature works there that
the cheaper the material the worse the
battery oftentimes and then I don't know
how that how they know yeah well the
world knows the whole industry is just
as trade off every time youth gas trains
one performance metric you're usually
sacrificing another which is where
you're leading before is you know even
with traditional chemistry's you can
make a special form of that battery that
will make one stat look amazing yeah so
maybe time for one more question and I'm
trying to sort of sup here one thing
that's also an undercurrent right now
from a research perspective going
forward I think in all at all areas that
we talk about especially here at CMU is
computational power is
machine learning is if data is an
assessment is it materials discovery
there's so many different flavors of it
and I know we're chasing in here in
multiple areas within CMU and if you
think I comment a little bit on that but
how about you other folks too what is
the future of all this new computational
power that we're seeing coming online
how is this gonna impact what we do so
last question good online what an
observation I had about about that when
I said that technology development will
be market driven there's stuff that is
possible today that we just never could
have done 10 15 years ago for example on
the market side we can now get multiple
20-year data sets hourly resolution wind
and make some assumptions about
different battery characteristics and
run a techno-economic model to run
optimizing scenarios for what
combination of solar plus storage or
wind plus storage or both creates the
cost minimizing levelized cost of
electricity that kind of stuff was never
possible before and that that helps us
tease out new sets of market
requirements that feed into the product
development process we can say how
important is efficiency and you know one
striking realization we had was that if
you're looking in a to a future where
there's a 1 cent per kilowatt hour PPA
efficiency is less important than we
thought and that relaxing that design
constraint can really change your
options for technology development and
that that kind of market-based
computation just was not possible and
just be clear when Ted says we he means
the form energy team informant and by
the way it was the first investment of
from Dave Danielson steam and BV so it's
an ultra long duration storage and
they're figuring out a way to crack that
at that problem so we have just a minute
left or or less so please fast and
concise eli is probably going to talk
about data so I'm gonna talk about the
the piece related to being able to do
everything on the computer never have to
test and then the experiment is just
validation and you might think this is
pie in the sky idea but the steel
industry is gotten there what Calafat
the thermodynamics models are so good
that in experimentation is largely
validation where are we on getting there
with batteries but
not there yet the materials project has
made phenomenal progress at sort of
collecting the data and trying to sort
of build that piece but in ten years I
would be very surprised if we cannot
with 99% accuracy predict the voltage
curve of any battery material I will be
very quick because I don't do a lot of
software and just agree with you that
that that's where the direction would go
so let's see two quick things one thing
that we see happening is you know we
think that right now it's happening with
lithium the costs are going down things
are becoming commoditized we see that
following a similar sort of trajectory
to the semiconductor market over the
last couple decades where they went from
being a very expensive relatively rare
to neither ubiquitous and generally
speaking very cheap very low margin
business hard business there's a
tremendous amount of optimization to be
done in throughout that supply chain and
manufacturing chain that's can be
enabled by computers and data analysis
and then the second thing that I'll say
is in terms of deploying these systems
at scale somebody needs to pay for them
they need to be financed they need to be
insured all that capital hates
uncertainty there's still a tremendous
amount of uncertainty around how these
systems are going to perform in the
field so again going back to the data
thing it's gonna be about collecting a
lot of data and then being able to model
that and model the financial
implications of the actual physical
state of the battery not just modeling
what the sort of how you optimize when
you charge and discharge to maximize the
revenues all right well without taking
up any more time I want to thank you
guys I wanna I wanna I want to throw a
last question back to you or so that I
think everyone wants to know what
battery 2.0 in Jays mind is so I think
we should close with that that's it so
it's a fair question wow I I don't know
yet actually I'm thinking about battery
3.0 I'm sitting battery 2.0 out and I'm
waiting for you guys to do that and then
I will follow up with battery 3.0 in
about six or seven years no I think that
to be honest with you I think that the
answer is some hybrid of what Ted is
going after and
some of the lithium-ion folks recovering
after I think we have to find a battery
2.0 for me because of the incredible
pressure from a manufacturing
infrastructure perspective to devote
immense capital to scale down to cost we
have to design batteries that are useful
for both stationary and mobile
applications somehow and this is hard to
do because that an optimized battery for
a car is totally different than a
battery without device for stationary
storage right now and if we could find a
way to create a Silver Bullet chemistry
or cell configuration or something that
will allow for both of those markets to
be served perfectly or well because
right now like Tesla solution of putting
its battery cells into a package a
hanging on a wall is not actually a good
stationary storage plate it just it's
not I mean it it's great the Tesla's
doing it in their popularizing the idea
but electric chemically it's not the
right answer
so battery 2.0 in my mind or maybe 3.0
is something that is both that can do
both things because you'd love to
leverage the two you know the two
markets and people talk about doing it
now but it's more difficult so with that
thank our audience
[Applause]